und kannst dir auf frisch alles in den
warenkorb klappen was du willst ganz
wichtig bis 500 euro er über geht nicht
mehr
was ist wenn ich ehrlich bin die
playstation das ist was ist das denn
also ich bin mir sicher das ist keine
playstation aber mal gucken was ankommt
[Musik]
bleibt und man sich schon seit und
astronom ich gut drauf
hey leute was gedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem niedrigen leute was
geht ab jetzt starb er ist häufig eine
intrige nein das passt ja schon etwas
gedacht und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch witz gut daher
ist häufig niedriger heute ungefähr vor
einer woche oder zwei wochen kam das
video mit maria online und zwar durch
schließlich hat das gesehen bestimmt und
zwar durfte die sich bei amazon in fünf
minuten aussuchen was sie möchte das
ganze auf grund eines amazon gutscheins
den ich jeden monat eigentlich zur
verfügung habt komischerweise habe ich
denn jetzt noch nicht bekommen ich habe
mein bruder aber auch gesagt dass wir
das auch mal zusammen machen können dann
hatte ich mir schon ganz gut drauf
gefreut und damit das jetzt nicht wieder
das gleiche wird und dass so ein
bisschen abwechslungsreiches habe ich
beschlossen dass jetzt nicht auf amazon
zu machen sondern auch wunsch ja vor
drei tagen kamen auch mein letztes buch
video wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen
habt ist am ende verlinkt lohnt sich so
also kurz die spielregeln für die
nächste noch nicht wissen ich hoffe du
hast hier ein bisschen gedanken gemacht
hier ist gleich eine stoppuhr die geht
bis fünf minuten du hast fünf minuten
zeit und kannst hier auf frisch alles in
den warenkorb klappen was du willst ganz
wichtig bis 500 euro er drüber geht
nicht mehr
was ist wenn ich fertig bin ja dann
kannst du dir was ist denn das für eine
aussage dann kannst du kannst doch nicht
fällig sein denn bestellst du halt noch
mehr oder wie versteht
kein plan er weiß ich bestellen soll ja
ich komme hier gibts doch alles mögliche
glaube ich einfach irgendwann tragen ja
dann kannst du irgendwas das ist ja der
sinn der sache du kannst alles ein
klopfen
ja mein weg auch die fußcreme wir wollen
gar nicht lange land fünf minuten laufen
ab jetzt sofort und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß schreibt gern mal in die
kommentare was würdet ihr euch bestellen
wenn ihr die möglichkeit hätte unseren
tollen bruder hättet wie mich studieren
wir die stoffe die wird auch für euch
eingeblendet ich würde sagen warum liegt
das vielleicht haben wir nicht so gut
das internet doch das müsste aber lagen
wenn das jetzt aufgrund des internets
nicht schnell lagen sollte wenn man das
wenn ich das merkte dann gebe ich dir
sechs minuten für alles okay oder halt
dann auch 7g nachdem also leute auf die
plätze bis 3 auf die plätze fertig zeit
läuft ab jetzt so
so kann man mit zwei fingern zu gehst du
kannst hier oben suchen
lass dir zeit
[Musik]
jetzt macht iphone case super super eine
simple das bestimmt original das kann
nur original seit april schon mal hier
für einen euro na ja ach ja gucken erst
mal in ruhe was hier so gefällt ja
erstmal in ruhe alles an mit 100 liege
die nimmst du jetzt mehr von sonko oder
wie heißt der jetzt willst du die größe
was willst du haben ja nix iphone xo ich
machte mir jetzt hast du schon mal eine
sache jetzt kannst du weiter gucken und
ich kann dir mal ein kleiner tipp geben
ein bisschen beeilen weil eine minute 15
haben schon jetzt machen wir hin
dann könnte sie machen was dich doch
einfach irgendwas rein playstation 4
ja was ist das denn
einfach ingo playstation das ist was ist
das display ist also ich bin mir sicher
das ist keine flächen aber mal gucken
was ankommt ok weiter jetzt turbo hier
wireless charging geht das bei deinem
handy also ein habe ich sogar schon aber
egal auf 142 euro
grüße was für sky von iks so wir haben
jetzt schon drin ein wireless charging
eine ps4 und eines hugo puzzle höher
aufgeben wollen sie hat jetzt auch lust
geht auch hier gehen wir hier auf
express.de auto express
die hose euro erwartet was menschliche
größe
was gibt's dann messen so steht dort
noch mal einfach no2 prognose so der
türkei kleiner zwischenstand wir sind
ungefähr bei der hälfte zwei minuten 45
hast du hast ja das passt ja richtig
zusammen die helfer wirklich halten kann
man hier von 230 euro runtergesetzt eine
andere stimmt achja trinke ja in ruhe
mein kaffee kommt der donner oder soll
man besseres niedrig zu nehmen
die westlichste grüßten ihn keine ahnung
wie man den verträgen müssen
das habe ich ja bei mir bei marie habe
ich das auch schon nicht verstanden
wieso ähnlich einfach hier alles
reinhaut das geht doch so schnell hier
ich würde das anklicken
mit einem doppelklick ja die sieht ja
super aus kommen herein lustig wird hier
mit dem doppel wie klingt im neuen tab
öffnen dann einfach alles rein ball ja
ich kann ich komme mir nicht zurecht
guck mal hier eine hose gibt da noch
irgendwas ein was brauchst du denn noch
was wolltest du schon immer haben
nike schuhe ja sicherlich gibt es sehr
gute nix so welche wünsche haben ich
mache das jetzt mal dir oder die ja dann
warte mal die hier nun die die idee die
ja die hier die hier ja das alles so
freundlich war gut dann hat keiner
adidas also eigentlich sind wir schon
bei fünf minuten ich gebe dir sechs okay
weil du es bist was ist damit der schule
ja ja kommen jetzt nämlich einfach egal
ja dann nehme ich das wir nun betreuen
willst du nicht die farben noch mal
überdenken nicht schwierig weil sie
anders aussehen du nimmst du jetzt noch
mal ja gut so und damit ist die zeit
auch genau jetzt abgelaufen wir sind
hier bei 6 minuten
hast du richtig gut gemacht das war
nicht zu schlagen
selbst ja gut elf jahren sind jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt ob also ich habe ja am
anfang gesagt warum ist die gute
ministerin gemacht
ich hatte am anfang gesagt bis 500 euro
wir fangen jetzt hier mal an und zwar
mit den genossen denn hier zwei von
bestellt als rechter oder nicht
wir haben hier einmal die apple airport
die von welcher marke auf immer sind
dann haben wir gleich noch mal
wie soll ich die becken ist nicht
einfach bei google
man muss ja also nicht mal selber zahlen
also hätte ich hättest du willst gesagt
ich darf das machen die genommen wenn du
zahlst in der unten mit zwei märkten
einbringen ach so ja anscheinend hast
zwei mal rein gemacht also dann haben
wir hier die originale goldene rolex
eine bank diese jacke die finde ich echt
gut also
keine ahnung die habe ich vorher noch
nie ausgesehen und ich kann mich
eigentlich recht gut aus kostet auch 20
euro aber bin ich mal gespannt wie die
aussieht dann haben wir eine
streitschrift skinny jeans für 12 euro
bin ich auch mal gespannt ob die so
aussieht wie auf diesem bild weil sieht
gut aus oder ja könnte man auch mal
schnaps kaufen würde ja so dann haben
wir hier noch einen wireless charging
iphone also das teil habe ich mir auch
schon mal bestellt in irgend einem video
von mir
das hat bei mir allerdings nicht
funktioniert bis mir einige leute in die
kommentare geschrieben haben das
funktioniert auch noch gar nicht bei ihm
wenn die das funktioniert glaube ich er
sagt warum redest du immer so leise weil
sie nicht an gewohnt so dann haben wir
hier erst mal auf das denn viele habe
ich nämlich auch schon gemacht letztlich
zu nehmen
nein das hat nichts damit zu tun ich
habe letztens ein ipad bestellt und an
kam nur so eine tastatur dafür und zwar
musste immer lesen was ihr steht
erst hierdurch controller charger h
weißt du das ist nicht die ps4 das ist
einfach nur hier diese ladestation dafür
sieht man das anders hingegen müssen
nein die prestigo kanzler keine ps4
beständigen und dann haben wir zum
schluss noch die supreme goku dies von
supreme für drei euro 80
gut insgesamt kommen wir hier auf 159
euro 10 inklusive versand versand 58
euro das ist dann einfach mit der leute
weißt du noch irgendwas ergänzen oder so
oder reicht bis hin zu glänzen ja keine
ahnung florian muss 100 leute wir machen
das so wie beim letzten mal da kamen mir
das video dann auch in der woche später
mit den sachen wo sie anhalt angekommen
nimmt das problem ist bei mir dauert das
immer ein bisschen länger deswegen würde
ich mal schätzen das video kommt
frühestens in drei wochen dann sind die
sachen gut
ja danke dass du dabei warst aber ich
glaube du müsstest dich bei mir bedanken
oder das war's mit dem video wir sehen
uns übermorgen wieder und wenn ich mal
gespannt wann der ganze gang kommt
warum gibt es heute wieder von mir
lieber wenn die an die das video kommt
ihr denn morgen oder heute so
kommt drauf an okay ich bin ja dann
sollten auf instagram nicht jetzt im
frühjahr wenn das dann hier irgendwo ein
wenn du glück hast nicht richtig leute
das war's haut rein ziehe